why should you care about ukraine you
should care about ukraine because this
was a country that all they were doing
was minding their own business they were
trying to be free and what you've got is
you've got tyrants around the world i
saw this at the united nations russia
and china started to get together not
because they like each other not because
they trust each other but because the
one unifying thing for both of them is
they want to destroy the west they want
to destroy democracy they want to
destroy freedom and they're going to do
whatever they can to do that the reason
you should care about ukraine is because
if russia gets away with this taiwan is
next and china will take taiwan it's not
if it's when and when they do taiwan
produces you know half of the the world
semiconductor chips so for all of your
viewers if you like your phone if you
like your computer if you like your car
all these things that we now
electronically or can't live without
china would literally own us
did ukraine just not understand
full geopolitics and giving up nukes i
mean at the end of the day that you have
to be uh responsible for your own
security even if everything was right in
the u.s and and the world was really
trying to do the best they could that at
the end of the day it still is about you
defending yourself
well you know i think ukraine tried to
do the right thing you know what they
did was
in the name of peace
they said okay we won't produce we'll
give ours up
but history will now look back and i
think ukrainians are probably looking
back going should we have done that and
i think now that you know the rest of
the world's going to look at that and
that's why you're going to see
all the talks about you know
denuclearizing are going to be on pause
for a good while
so you know i'm with you on the you sort
of have to have peace through strength
but there i do also have a uh a strong
libertarian side and part of me right
now and i'm hearing this from my
audience also people are just kind of
like you know we're so screwed up in
this country right now
all the woke stuff and critical race
theory and the border and inflation
and supply chain and of course we can
relate some of that back to the energy
which gets us to russia but that there's
just so many problems right now it's
like can't someone else
do something right now and i am somewhat
sympathetic to that even hearing the
arguments like there is part of me
that's just like maybe
there's just too much to chew off right
now especially because i just don't have
faith in our leaders right now if we had
leaders that i had faith in maybe i
would feel a little bit differently
well you know i've always had a
libertarian streak to me too and i think
that you know government needs to stay
out of a lot of things and we would be
much better off but what i will tell you
is we always have to fight for freedom
and the reason we fight for freedom is
because it could you know the threats
could end up on our doorstep why should
you care about ukraine you should care
about ukraine because this was a country
that all they were doing was minding
their own business they were trying to
be free and what you've got is you've
got tyrants around the world i saw this
at the united nations russia and china
started to get together not because they
like each other not because they trust
each other but because the one unifying
thing for both of them is they want to
destroy the west they want to destroy
democracy they want to destroy freedom
and they're going to do whatever they
can to do that the reason you should
care about ukraine is because if russia
gets away with this taiwan is next
and china will take taiwan it's not if
it's when and when they do taiwan
produces you know half of the the world
semiconductor chips so for all of your
viewers if you like your phone if you
like your computer if you like your car
all these things that we now
electronically or can't live without
china would literally own us we would be
in the same situation situation that
europe is with russia on the dependency
of of energy we would be in that same
dependency with china and china would
not be near as kind as russia i can
promise you that they're stronger
they're sleeker they're smarter and
they're more determined than ever to
ruin the west and so these are all
places we have to care about because if
if it's another country it could be us
and we're not saying go to war i'll be
the first one to say
as a wife of a combat veteran that's a
last resort what i am saying is use the
power of our voice for good
use the fact that we do have military
arms that we can send for good use the
fact that we can help get our allies
together to become less dependent on
russia so they don't put all of us in a
bad situation so that we can really get
more alliances together that's all for
good that's not you know that's not
going to war that's not getting
government involved that's saying we're
going to protect freedom and we have to
protect freedom wherever it reigns
how much of this do you blame on the
biden administration i mean you were uh
at the u.n under president trump you
know it's not that we had perfect world
peace obviously but putin was quiet when
it came to ukraine he did some stuff
crimea under obama uh but there was
certainly the feeling that if he did
something
under trump who obviously was like well
what would trump do so he didn't do any
you know so putin didn't make a move how
much of this do you blame on on biden
you mentioned keystone pipeline i mean
we're reliant on the bad guys this is a
problem
and biden is has really really done this
to all of us and i will tell you this
never would have happened under
president trump um and it was because
president trump
really kind of laid it out there for all
the tyrants out there but president
trump did something that russia
absolutely disliked he built up our
military which russia never wanted us to
do he made sure we were energy
independent which russia didn't like and
he made sure that he
would not allow nordstrom 2 to go
through which was going to be a big
revenue source
for russia but what's happened since
then president biden
now comes into office
he allows afghanistan to fall but not
only did afghanistan fall what they saw
was the united states left bagram air
force base in the middle of the night
without telling the allies who stood
shoulder to shoulder with us for two
decades without telling them that we
were doing it
big signal to our enemies big signal to
our elements then you go forward and he
goes and waves nordstrom too a gift to
putin at a time that he needed it then
you add on to that biden's falling all
over himself to get into the iran deal i
mean that the weakness of that when iran
wouldn't even let the us in the room
biden's begging to get back into a deal
with the number one state sponsor of
terror and then finally you see biden
speak
and what does he say he says well if
it's a minor incursion we'll do one
thing if it's an invasion we'll do
another
those were all green lights for putin
putin knew that never again would we
have a weak president like this in
america and it's the same thing
president xi sees in china they see it
they know there's an opportunity putin
chose to move on it it never would have
happened under president trump because
there was never any weakness there was
deterrence under president trump do you
think putin's a little surprised that it
seems like the whole world has rallied
around this i mean you know they're
talking about kicking them off the swift
system and the sanctioning of the
oligarchs and all of this stuff i i
don't know that it's going to work
exactly but do you think he's a little
surprised how quickly things came to be
although they did russia did veto their
security council members so they vetoed
the un security council resolution which
is sort of hilarious i suppose in a
depressing sense
i think he's completely taken aback i
mean i don't think that he thought that
um
you know that he was going to see this
much resistance i don't think he thought
that president zielinski would become
this much of a hero um i don't think he
knew the courage and inspiration um that
the ukrainian people would be to the
world and so you know what you've got as
ukrainians picking up knives from their
kitchens if they have to they're you
know standing up in front of tanks
they're
you know picking up guns from anywhere
and they're fighting back for their
freedom and fighting back to their
country we should take a lesson from
them on how much they are doing to
protect being free how precious being
free actually is and so i think putin's
absolutely taken back and i think she
sees putin is sloppy i think that he's
he's looking at how putin did this and
he's looking at putin made mistakes but
the way president xi is looking at this
is
he's very much paying attention to every
country that's giving ukraine arms he's
paying attention to every company that's
no longer doing business with russia
he's watching what's happening at the un
he's watching how the world is isolating
russia and he's not saying no i'm not
going to do this he's saying okay when i
do this i'm going to have to do it
differently and so it again
we can't take our eyes off of china
because china is going to be next what
we need to do is learn the lessons of
russia and see what happens when
division comes in
which is what happened with us and our
allies when we look distracted it opens
a door for these thugs to do
um you know the devil's work and that's
exactly what they're doing if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell